nous venons de mettre en place une
grande nouveauté l'entrée une plate
forme téléphonique pour contacter
individuellement et en lien avec les
rectorats chaque décrocheur une
plateforme lancée en mai dernier son
objectif contacter 100% des décrocheurs
ils sont vingt mille en ile de france
qu'ils soient collégiens et lycéens
il ya beaucoup de travaille déjà pour
appréhender vraiment le nombre et la
situation de ces décrocheurs
et puis lorsque nous aurons vraiment
contacter chacun et fiabiliser ce
fichier et nous mettons tous les moyens
pour le faire rapidement prendre au
moins un décrocheur sur deux en charge
tant des dispositifs qui existent ça
change complètement toute l' approche
décrochage ou jusqu'à présent et bien
financer des écoles de la deuxième
chance des structures de raccrochage
mais sans se soucier si elles étaient
pleines ou si elle était vide
et si les jeunes y avaient accès ou pas
est donc là on va aller chercher les
jeunes c'est ça pour nous le social
efficace pour cette rentrée la région
ile de france vise aussi la restauration
scolaire d'ici 2024
elle veut atteindre 100% des cantines en
circuit court avec 50 % de produits bio
l'île de france le produit pas tous
qu'on aura les partenariats avec les
autres régions pour notre
approvisionnement mais on veut du
produit local
et puis on veut que dans ce produit
local 50% soit du produit piot nous
voulons cela parce que nous voulons à la
fois bien manger et nous voulons aussi
un bilan carbone positif de ce que nous
longeons 100 établissements en
bénéficient déjà pour cette rentrée à
saint quentin en yvelines sont concernés
les lycées 17 mar à maurepas rené
descartes emilie de breteuil à montigny
le bretonneux